uh good morning members and uh welcome
to this
animal council meeting on the 28th of
may i would like to introduce my
chaplain mark jones who will now lead us
in prayer a rare opportunity to see
mark live because we've always seen him
on the screen for the last year or so
thank you mark thank you john i'm sorry
i can't stay
uh for the meeting this morning as i
have another appointment but it's been a
real privilege to serve you all in this
way these past months as my mother
taught me to say
thank you for having me growing up as
children
i imagine most of us were raised to say
please and thank you
saying thank you has always been a
powerful thing
and i guess in 2020 we all became
experts in saying thank you
thank you to the nhs and other key
workers
and in deutsche as elsewhere we've been
thinking
who else could do with a thank you so
working together with
other local agencies we also thank
teachers firefighters ambulance through
doctor
surgeries essential uh shop workers and
pharmacists and lately we've also been
thanking the police
who really get thanked some of the
unsung heroes of the pandemic
and they face they literally thankless
task of trying to enforce
uh social distancing in paul's
first letter to the church in
thessalonica we read these simple words
give thanks in all circumstances
for this is god's will for you
now even in our darkest days there is
something we can give thanks for
and there's always someone to thank
the way our brains are wired
thankfulness
releases joy and joy
as we read in the scriptures is the
source of our strength
so with all this in mind let's give
thanks
and as ever if you're not a person of
faith
please use this time in whatever way
suits you to think
and reflect on these things
our father in heaven we thank you for
hearing our prayers
feeding us with your word and
encouraging us in our meeting together
over these past months that we have
journeyed together
we thank you for john's sacrificial
service to the community as chair of
team bridge district council
please take what he has offered multiply
it
and use it for the common good in the
months and years ahead
we thank you for all the counsellors
officers and staff of team bridge
district council
for their commitment to our local
communities
and for the personal cost to them
of both maintaining existing services
and pioneering
new initiatives we thank you for guiding
us through this long hard road of the
pandemic
and for leading us out the other side
into the hope
of better days ahead and because of the
wonderful vaccines much sooner than we
may have feared
we thank you for giving us this gift of
hope
the very thing that drives humanity
onward into the future
finally we thank you for each other
in jesus name amen
thank you mark thank you very much
indeed uh
meeting protocol for today members um
there is no fire alarm test plan today
however should the fire alarm plea sound
please leave the room at your nearest
exit
and meet at the front of the grandstand
which i believe is in that direction
please raise your hand if you wish to
speak and stay seated when speaking
please wait until the boom microphone is
brought to you
considering the configuration of the
room at the distance that people will
have to travel with the boom microphone
if you could keep any comments you wish
to make to the absolute minimum
and just consider the salient points
please
wearing a mask at all times unless
you're seated
and voting will be with a show of hands
are there any apologies for absence
counsellors bradford cook eden
haines and mcgregor thank you
minutes of the 22nd of april 2021
could i have a proposal for those please
unless there any objection sorry
are there any points that members wish
to raise before we go to the vote
i can't see any hands so could we have a
proposal please
counsel a con leader and a secondary
police councillor dew house thank you
uh can we go to the vote please on that
just raise your hands if you're in
agreement
so i think that's certainly a majority
for any against
no okay
chairs have to have perceptions please
sorry abstaining oh sorry any extensions
i can see one attention yes
thank you uh we're moving on to the
minutes of the extraordinary meeting
which was on the 4th of may
um can i have a proposal please
counselor conor and a second
councillor jewhorst um anybody would
like to raise any points regarding those
minutes
now can we go to the vote if you're in
favor please raise your hand
that seems very much like a majority um
any against
uh any attentions just one attention
thank you for that
item three are there any declarations of
interest
no uh announcements i've just got a
couple of announcements
um this sunday the 30th of may marks the
175th
anniversary of the timoth railway
station
a date which is also which sorry when it
was a date when it also became the
headquarters of the south devon railway
i would never have thought the building
was that old actually but it's quite
incredible uh the meeting is being
streamed live on youtube
and encounters uh wishing to speak
please wait until the blue microphone
comes to you otherwise you will be heard
on virtual media
[Music]
um
[Music]
look
[Music]
please
yeah right i'm trying to eat this but
i'll give it a go
listen i am very pleased to uh give you
great pleasure in fact
to nominate cancer colin parker is the
next chairman
of this team bridge district council
he uh as you know is a fellow councillor
of mine
representing buckland and milber along
with councillor jenks
and it gives me great pleasure therefore
to nominate
a a member from newton abbott
i've known colin as a friend and a
colleague for more years than perhaps
either of us
care to remember i find him to be
a loyal and respected friend and a
strong
family man he is devoted to his family
he is a man committed to his community
committed to his town where he has lived
for at least 40 years
he is devon born and bred made in deadly
you might say
incidentally a strong campaign which i'm
promoting
colin is an experienced counsellor who
has been a new nurturing counsellor
since 2007
14 years and a teenage district
counselor
since 2011. he was mayor of newton
abbott
in 2011-12 and has been chair of the
town's finance committee
for seven plus years he has spent
much of his life in the financial
services
industry colin will bring
experience therefore to this position
but he'll also be an extremely
fair-minded chairman
who will represent the district with
dedication and i believe
distinction he is in the fortunate
position of retiring from employment
by this time next week and will have the
time and energy therefore to represent
the council
in the various ways the position demands
i have no hesitation in strongly
recommending
councillor colin parker to you as the
next chair of the district
and i so move thank you thank you
councillor hope so proposed by
councillor hook
could i have a second to please cancel
alan the leader of the council
are there any other nominations for the
chair of council
in that case members will go to the vote
those in favor of uh councillor colin
parker become the chair of this
council please raise your hand
sarah i'll handle you at this stage
because you can see everyone
um do we have anyone against
anyone abstaining
that's carrie chair thank you very much
indeed for that
so i hand over now to councillor colin
parker before i go
i just like to say a few words that i
made please
uh normally at this time the outgoing
chair would describe the year that they
have just experienced in some detail
but the year that we have all
experienced together immediately just
words like challenge hardship and crisis
last year at this time it was doubtful
if any of us could have foreseen
what was on the horizon for us to face
as a district council
we have been confronted with creating
and adapting to new ways of working and
living our lives amid stressors
that we have never experienced before my
year as chairman is probably running
parallel to yours
lockdowns and virtual meetings but we
have managed
it really has been a year that we will
never forget i would like to thank our
staff for setting an extraordinary
example of commitment
professionalism and solidarity during
the coronavirus pandemic
i would like to thank in particular
sarah selway for supporting me through
an exceedingly difficult year
also thanks to my chaplain mark jones
mark is an exceptional guy
and i'm confident that you would agree
that mark has a different approach to
prayer
and his thoughtful delivery has
encouraged us all to listen and engage
with him
the chairman's charity fund this year i
advised some weeks ago
that due to an anonymous donation of 65
000 pounds
linda and i have met our target which
was beyond our wildest
dreams and we've been able to fund a
specially adapted minibus
for east seabridge community transport
association
colin parker is about to don the mantle
of chairman of timbers district council
i've known colin for 10 years and have
every confidence that will be an
excellent chairman and i wish you well
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
to have been nominated and elected to
the position of charity british district
council
rest assured i will treat the position
and the duties that come with
chairmanship with the highest regard
as the position demands i would like to
say before i go any further that i
commend cancer
on his year of chairmanship and related
duties
during this very challenging year
it was probably not the year he had
wished for being very difficult for all
of us
but he coped with it in a very dignified
manner
thank you and well done john thank you
leaning on from that we are obviously in
a much better position pandemic wise
than we have been for a long time but i
do stress
caution ongoing it will be a while i
feel
before we feel at ease with the
situation and things return
to relative normality
the fact that we're here today at this
racecourse venue
using as the most suitable and available
place
within the district demonstrate that
this is just a stepping stone
on the road back to our previous routine
routine
in respective announcements it is usual
for a chairman to announce a consort
chaplain and charity for the forthcoming
year
i intend to announce these in the
members newsletter
and then formally at our next full
council meeting
counsellors all through my working life
in my private life
and including the 14 years as a
counselor i've tried to treat
everyone that i have had personal
contact with the wider public also
in a straightforward respectful and fair
manner i will endeavor to continue
in that mode in this role
irrespective of our beliefs and views it
is my
expectation that all of us whether it be
in dealings with each other
officers and the general community that
we follow
similar principles
finally i would like to say thank you
again for putting the trust in me
and the trust from such a knowledgeable
group of counselors what you have given
to me
thank you all
like to move on to item seven now and
election vice chair and i'd like to call
for nominations for the position of vice
chairman of
district council cancer king
thank you mr chairman may i propose my
fellow church
counselor lorraine evans as the vice
chairman for team bridge district
council
thank you cancer colleen do we have a
second here for that nomination
uh councillor jefferies thank you
are there any other nominations
i don't see any so if we go to the vote
all those in favor as cancer lorraine
evans
let you check that sarah yeah have we
any against
thank you very much congratulations
cancer evans
i think we're going to do a brief
changeover
would you like to say a few words
yeah i'd just like to thank you all say
i'm delighted to accept the nomination
and thank you for your support
i look forward to supporting the council
in the coming year and supporting colin
parker and just to show you all that
i'll do my very best thank you
thank you lorraine thank you very much
we can now move on to
think all the itunes allocations have
been circulated
um so i'd like to ask for a proposer for
those nominations cancer count the
leader
and cancerdue has seconded
and can we go to the vote all in favor
any against abstentions
one at the back i think that's carrie
chair
thank you very much
moving swiftly on item nine
is the recommend recommendation from
executive on the housing strategy
i'd like to ask cancer wrigley the
portfolio holder to
propose this report thank you
thank you chair this is the regular
update of the housing strategy the
council's housing strategy setting our
direction
for 2021-26
firstly i'd like to thank all the
officers involved in pulling this
together it's been a
big undertaking and i think we have an
excellent strategy here
it's already gone through a wide
consultation
having had more responses to the
consultation than in previous years
and very largely positive it's gone
through overview and scrutiny and
through examination at the executive
it addresses three main areas delivery
of affordable homes
improving homes and preventing
homelessness and rough sleeping
i'll very very briefly just run through
what we're talking about in here
so open market planning obligation
section 106 will continue to deliver the
bulk of the affordable homes
however i draw your attention to the
housing register trends that show a
demand list of about a thousand
households
with some 400 housed each year and yet
demand remaining at around a thousand at
the end of the year
section 106 and registered providers are
just not able to provide sufficient
numbers
and central government plans not only
look likely to reduce numbers delivered
in this way
but this week have actually done so
tdc will add to the numbers through the
team bridge 100 program
this is a pipeline of 100 opportunities
to deliver some 25 to 50 new homes per
year
new opportunities being added as we
deliver homes
the key aim is to increase the number of
truly affordable
low carbon homes principally at social
rent
with high quality high efficiency and
minimal environmental impact
genuinely affordable to rent and
genuinely affordable to run
we also continue to encourage
community-led housing projects
and will deliver across villages rural
and town areas
we continue to work with private
landlords to help them improve the
condition of their properties
and offer grants and loans for home
improvements we have won several grant
funding opportunities to tackle fuel
poverty
and to provide air source heat pumps
into homes across the district
and will continue to focus on bringing
empty homes back into use
we also continue to focus on keeping
people independent at home
through disability facilities grants and
other schemes that we run
homelessness has a serious and harmful
effect on those who experience it
we aim to help people stay in their
homes if we can and if necessary
intervene to find new options
both temporarily and more permanently
we are developing a separate
homelessness and rough sleeping strategy
tackling homelessness and its causes
we also regularly apply for government
grants and we have recently
achieved another grant on the rough
sleeping initiative that will help us
further tackle homelessness in timbridge
the strategy was put out to consultation
received some five times the response
from five years ago
with predominantly positive comments and
some questions mostly on planning
issues in light of the
um executive recommendation i'd like to
propose that this council accepts and
adopts this housing strategy please
thank you cancer do we have a second for
that
cancer taylor
can we go to the vote are we all in
favor
are there certainly any questions
counselor
council parker khan
thank you chairman um there are elements
of this strategy
that i think are truly applaudable um
the homelessness strategy
and the improvement to to homes um
and elements of the affordable housing
program however there
are bits in here that it's it's not the
principle it's the proposed
implementation for delivery that i have
issue with so unfortunately i should be
abstaining on this occasion
thank you thank you ken supercar any
more questions
fine okay so we have a proposal under
secondary counselor taylor
all those in favor
you might need a count
sorry to keep your hands raised just for
a second
a number of abstentions
that's carried chair thank you thank you
very much
thank you councillor wrigley right
if we now move on to item 10 which is
counselors questions uh there are a
number i think seven in
all as you know each one
has been provided with a written
response
you can all ask each one of you can ask
a supplementary question
which has to be linked to the original
points
and there will be after the
supplementary question
has been answered there will be no
debating on the questions further
thank you if we could go to the first
question which is
thank you i've got a very brief uh
supplementary um i
would like this council and members to
be very much aware and i hope they will
stay aware that these proposals will
have a huge impact on this
council district council as 41 percent
of our council area falls within the
national park
and can also just please be aware that
any uh
planning uh decisions passed down to us
in the future as
um it will be to other constituent
planning authorities
and can i ask that we as a council um
continue to keep a close eye on this and
make sure that if
it does happen we have enough resources
to cope with the extra responsibility
we'll
have to put up with would the leader
like to respond to that
cancer comet
i'm grateful to councillor morgan for
the supplementary i think we all need to
remain
vigilant of course i think the council
will rely on council morgan and cancer
natalie who are
representatives on the dartmouth
national park authority to ensure that
we are up to date with all of the
information
and what not my national park authority
is doing as well
i'm also very mindful of the potential
additional burden and cost to team
bridge
if we have to inherit the planning
responsibilities of the dartmouth
national park authority in my view
this is an ill judge and ill-considered
proposal
and that the dartmouth national park
authority does a very good job
and is well regarded and is one of those
things that is not broken and doesn't
need fixing
uh but if a government their intent on
this folly
we will be vigilant and we rely on you
and counselor natalie to keep us
informed as well thank you
thank you second question
is from cancer nutley do you have a
supplementary counselor
thank you chairman um no i don't have a
second question but uh i would just like
to echo the response from my colleague
councillor morgan
and also the answer that our leader has
given me and i appreciate
all their help thank you
thank you councillor nutley okay then we
move on to the
the third question which is uh from
first of two from cancer bulletin
do you have a supplementary cancer
element
thank you i'm grateful for the
opportunity to ask a supplementary
question
the first question related to the
extremely welcome investment that
is coming for the development of the
a382 as you know the a382 forms one
edge of my ward and over the last 18
months
my residents have suffered a tremendous
amount of just
inconvenience because of the uh longer
running at overrunning roadworks
i'm grateful for the response provided
but i would
emphasize that we need to have a proper
program
so my residents can understand how long
they're going to have to put up with the
disruption
that's caused by these welcome
improvements and what mitigation efforts
are going to be put in place to minimize
those and the impact it has on on my
residents
so yes i welcome the uh proposals
but can the executive please recognize
the need for information for
uh the residents to allay their fears
about the ongoing delays
thank you thank you council bulletin um
councillor taylor taylor would you like
to respond
uh thank you uh thank you for the
question uh council development and uh
yes it
uh this investment is uh certainly
welcome and we do
appreciate that where programmers do
fall behind
for whatever reason it does have an
effect on
on the local people and that their
travel
so so yes we we would like to put
mitigation measures in as as we as we
can
and certainly we will uh focus on the
program now that we are emerging from
kobe
thank you councillor taylor um question
four
uh council beloved again any
supplementary
thank you i welcome the opportunity to
comment on the response given
back in 2016-17 this council recognized
that the
problems caused by developers failing to
adhere to their
conditions that were granted at the time
of approvals for development were given
were causing issues with residents
a process was introduced for
site visits to take place on sites of
over 50 homes
to ensure that the appropriate
conditions were being applied
and met during the development phase
it's extremely disappointing to note
that of the 11
schemes that have commenced only five
since then have had the benefit of such
visits i welcome the comment that that
situation is recognized as a problem by
the uh
executive and they've confirmed that the
relevant meetings will
take place in the future can i have the
assurance that
the executive recognize how important
these site visits are made
to ensure that the problems associated
with develops
are addressed at the earliest possible
stage and mitigated as soon as they
possibly can be
thank you thank you cancer but cancer
taylor would you like to respond to that
again
thank you again for the uh for the
question uh relating to this
uh site to site visits and yes as i'm
sure
all of us appreciate uh site visits have
been
uh curtailed due to cover 19
and that has resulted in uh in
some watering down perhaps of
the uh of the situation i would like to
give your
give assurance that you know now that
site meetings are
uh back back in order uh we will be
we will be putting in place the
necessary investigations
thank you thank you councillor taylor
okay if we could move on to question
five
and the response that was from cancer
malone do you have a supplementary
counselor malone
hi um yeah i think the leader for his
response to this question um
however the response seems to intimate
that whenever a
a site is put forward it it has to be
considered
um however suitable or unsuitable
but we know that this isn't the case we
know that a lot of sites are put forward
and are rejected out of hand for reasons
of flooding or because
uh you just consider that they're in the
wrong place so my question is
considering that this these proposals
contain
areas of special scientific interest and
playgrounds
my question is broadly you know
what is sacrosanct to you what what is
though that could be put forward for
planning
that you wouldn't consider for reasons
of its public immunity
thank you councilman uh councillor
taylor again
working you today gary
so so the question is what will we not
consider
and certainly there have been some sites
that have been uh
rejected or considered and and put to
one side
that were felt by the
healer panel which is the housing and
economic uh
lance availability assessment
which were found to not be able to be
developable
at all for uh for
various reasons certain sites
certain large sites in particular may
have areas
which could be developed with suitable
mitigation
and those sites have now come forward
uh for further consultation with with
the uh
through public consultation i i would
also add that
this particular site will be reviewed
following input from natural england
and with due regard to the planning
guidance for the south ham's
special area of conservation concerning
the protection of habitats for the
greater horseshoe bat
so i hope this will go some way into
assuaging the concerns
from the member on this subject
thank you cancer taylor thank you very
much
right we move on to question six which
was from councillor bradford
and there's been a written answer
council bradford is not present today
uh given her apologies so there will be
no supplementary so
we'll move straight on to question seven
which i think was from councillor dawes
um
there's been a written answer would you
like a supplementary cancer rules
thank you thanks uh thanks for the
answer the question pertained to the
uh the commitment council to retain the
integrity of the alexandria theatre
um when i was 30 years old i was uh
invited by a progressive
forward-thinking and inclusive council
in brighton hove to chair a creative
industry
industries group but 20 years after that
uh i've run venues uh venues that have
won
more comedy children comedy awards than
any other operator in the country
uh been awarded the arts council england
award for best
family friendly theater in the southeast
and were cited
in government reports of the deputy
prime minister of the sort of venues
that every
town and city should have in their uh
in their nighttime economy uh also on
your council you have councillor
janet bradford who uh over 20 years
introduced
thousands of tens of thousands of
children into theater through her work
with stage coaching
uh torky and newton abbott uh and
counselor malone who's operated
at the largest uh arts festival in the
world
uh very effectively in the comedy
industry for for
a decade plus what i'm actually
wondering is why
when you have this expertise within the
council elected
by the residents to represent their
interests why
are overtures of engagement on the
alexandra theatre have been
ignored and and pushed to one side
we we have an executive that has invited
uh opposition members on at great cost
to the residents uh what we are offering
are our skills our input uh
and our engagement at no cost to the
residents
uh in their very best interest so i
implore
the uh the executive uh to take on board
our offer
uh and uh also to do at the same time to
engage with the friends of the alexander
theatre
and any other groups who have an
interest in retaining that space
thank you thank you councillor dawes uh
councillor jeffies would you like to
respond to that please
and thank you councillor for your
comments um
yeah it's it's great that we have such a
wealth of experience within a council
and it does go beyond those councillors
that you have just mentioned
and it extends out into the community as
well so i think moving forward we know
that we have great enthusiasm about um
what's happening
with within newton abbott in terms of
the vibrancy of the town
and the offer from the communities and
the offer from this council
and there will definitely be some
collaboration going forward to find out
what's needed
and to make the town as vibrant as
possible so thank you for noting
and we'll move forward
thank you councillor jefferies uh that
comes the end of the council of
questions
um we'll move on to item 11
notices of motion now there are two
notice emotions here
both put in by people who are not here
today given their apologies
and they have requested that these
notice emotions are deferred
until the next council meeting so
i would like to from the chair propose
that for
councillor mcgregor's notice of motion
that we defer this
to our next meeting um
could i have a secretary for that
proposal please
counter bulletin all those in favor that
we defer
i think that's uh most everyone
any against any abstentions
one at the back okay that's carrie
that's deferred to the next meeting
and then we've got another notice of
motion from cancer eden who also
apologizes
and is requested the same that it be
deferred until the next meeting
so from the chair i would like to
propose that we defer
this notice of motion to the next full
council meeting
could i have a second here for that
please cancel bulletin
thank you very much uh all those in
favor that we defer
any against none against any abstentions
no abstentions so that's carried and
moved to the next meeting
right i think very very swiftly
councillors that
more or less come to the end of the
meeting i would just like to wind up and
say
thank you very much again for entrusting
me in this position as chair
i hope to live up to expectations and
thank you very much everyone and such an
unusual meeting
um we'll get back to normality hopefully
as soon as possible
thank you one and all and i believe i
have to say that can you leave the
building um
sorry to say like this as swiftly as
possible you can talk outside
but could you leave the building as soon
as possible
thank you
thank you alan thank you very much